how exciting was that to be up there to
have all that stuff behind you
well bobby we are certainly not used to
those bells and whistles yeah
overwhelming it was overwhelming and
just very like i think it definitely
elevated our performance just to feel
all of the creative hands
working and you know it's like you want
to live up to that you know all the work
that's been put into it you want to you
want to put in the work too and so
um it was just a lot of fun to run
around that stage with the all the rocks
and stuff for the chain
and just feel the moment
yeah
what a gift what a gift we were given
yeah that only comes around once only
once a time
knows what to come around when you go on
your world tour for winning the voice
that's what's going to come around
yeah
i like the way you're thinking
well congratulations someone leave
everybody jump in
um okay um mark
mark
hi folks
congratulations
great job tonight i kelly mentioned the
chain that you had in your pocket was
that a song that you knew all along that
if you made the finale you wanted to
hang on to it and pull it out
at this moment
that's right if we made it to the finale
we were like we got to sing the chain
everybody was requesting it
everybody we had never sang it before
like in our concerts but we just knew
that and we had worked on an arrangement
in the last couple weeks last six weeks
and we
were excited to do it yeah
oh wow i assume this is one maybe you
felt really comfortable with because you
performed it multiple times before
no
no that was we just had a feeling it was
going to be awesome yeah
how did it feel in that performance in
particular how did you feel on stage
tonight
so good for me personally i
was really able to be present um i
was like looking at my siblings and and
just really able to
be there which hasn't really happened in
a performance
yet um i didn't have anything else going
on in my head i was just able to live
the song with with them and so i'm
really grateful for that um
yeah something always have
terrific well congratulations and good
luck tomorrow night i'll yield for
someone else if there's more time to
come back thanks mark thanks hey um et
canada could you guys want to take it
nikki
sure thank you so much um one of the
most touching things i think was the
letters that you guys wrote to each
other it was so sweet um what has it
been like getting to go through this
together as a family and just having
that support system with you throughout
the entire time
having each other by our sides has made
all the difference i think you know we
individually we are solid performers but
like bringing it together we we have
something created that none of us can
accomplish on our own so to just be able
to go on stage together to do life
together outside of rehearsals and
everything it's really brought us closer
and our parents back home are you know
wishing us the best and
it's real light in their life to see us
out here living our dreams
wonderful thank you
yeah
great thanks okay belinda
hello guys congratulations on another
successful
so when i find out from you guys what do
you think you learned the most about
yourself during this competition
i think what we learned
the most about this whole process is
that what we do bring to the table is
it and they're choosing to go on their
phones and listen to it having a
single go to number one on the itunes
charts really was um
evidence that folks do really want us in
their ears and so as musicians that's
really affirming that's given us a new
confidence and going forward when we're
writing i think we
you know
people are going to be listening to this
stuff and and we want to do our very
best
for ourselves and and for what the world
needs right now
okay well i think i think that's
everything mark did you have one more
question we can probably squeeze in
another one if you have one more
yeah it's real simple roughly in about
24 hours carson's going to say a name as
the winner of the voice
what happens if he says you guys win
oh my lance if carson says that we win i
am going to be utterly shocked because
mark you saw a talent on that stage
tonight
i mean
everybody deserves that title and we are
going to be celebrating no matter whose
name is called
and we're just so grateful to have made
it this far to have done our best with
every performance and
to take home a victory would be sweet i
won't lie but also
it's already victorious
you